creator Robert Kirkman is finally ready
to talk about what caused the fictional
zombie pandemic in The Walking Dead for
fans who have been following the story
of The Walking Dead since Rick Grimes
first awoke from his coma back in 2003
this revelation is a long time coming
it's actually impressive that Kirkman
has kept his cards so close to his vest
for so long considering the franchise
has expanded to infect every quadrant of
our media world video games books TV you
name it
now having reached the epic conclusion
of his long-running tale at least in
comic form Kirkman must have decided it
was finally time to dole out a little
fanservice
early on in the comic series it's
revealed that every human in the world
is already infected with the zombie
pathogen while zombie bites accelerate
the transformation any death eventually
results in zombification we've seen
survivors navigate every facet of this
deadly scenario without any
understanding of the zombie hordes
origins well wonder no more on Twitter
Kirkman finally confirmed that the cause
of this pandemic is extraterrestrial in
nature
[Music]
aliens specifically the zombie virus
came from a space spore in Kirkman zone
words
Kirkman has long credited the work of
late horror movie director George a
Romero as a key inspiration for The
Walking Dead he said on numerous
occasions that his entire magnum opus
resulted from the question what if a
zombie movie just kept going in light of
this the space spore explanation may be
yet another homage to Romero
particularly his iconic zombie flick
Night of the Living Dead where in the
zombie apocalypse has potentially been
instigated by radiation released from a
space probe to Venus that's the space
vehicle which orbited Venus and then
prim was purposely destroyed by NASA
when scientists discovered it was
carrying a mysterious high-level
radiation fans weren't sure they'd ever
get a straight answer from Kirkman as to
what started the zombie virus in The
Walking Dead in a 20-18 Q&A on tumblr he
dismissed the notion of revealing the
source of the zombie contagion as
irrelevant to the story saying maybe
years after it's all over I'll just
casually mention it in an interview that
seems like a very JK rowling thing to do
shots fired
fortunately for curious fans it seems
like Kirkman found his inner rolling on
the surface it may not seem like
Kirkman's earthbound tale of humans
surviving against impossible odds has
much to do with extraterrestrials but
the alien explanation has always been
bubbling around the edges of the Walking
Dead when Kirkman and his creative team
originally pitched the idea to Image
Comics Kirkman had to concoct an
outlandish backstory for the series just
to catch executives attention at that
time he told the substantial white lie
that the zombie pandemic in The Walking
Dead was designed by aliens who intended
to use the zombie apocalypse to make
earth a softer target for invasion
although Kirkman was pretty clear that
this was never really his team's
intention it wasn't the last mention of
ETS in The Walking Dead history well not
necessarily canon a bonus ending for
issue number 75 was inspired by this
misleading pitch in this sci-fi reskin a
lightsaber wielding Michonne explains
that hostile aliens unleashed the zombie
horde to turn humanity into a race of
slaves bound into service by harvesting
water which their alien overlords used
as
see how's that for an alternate ending
aside from the explanation of the virus
being totally irrelevant to the comic
series Kirkman also believes that the TV
iterations of his work are unlikely to
explore either the source of or cure for
the virus while certain fans may prefer
a pat resolution to the apocalypse
plaguing the world of The Walking Dead
Kirkman's instincts are probably spot-on
the third TV series for the franchise
The Walking Dead world beyond takes
place a decade after the beginning of
the zombie pandemic with a set of young
protagonists still grappling with the
world of the undead at the end of the
world was our beginning the lack of a
cure is definitely organic to Kirkman's
original vision The Walking Dead has
never been a series about finding a
miraculous cure it's a story about
survivors re-establishing a new normal
in a world that will never be the same
discovering a cure would undermine the
entire premise but hey at least we
officially know what started the
collapse in the first place check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite shows are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the belt
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]